Running a marathon is tough.
But what about running one in space?
But how hard can that be?
Hello moon walkers, Lissette here for DNews.
Astronauts in space live in a whole different
world.
And one of the biggest differences, besides
probably the lack of oxygen, is the lack of
gravity.
Thanks to this we have some pretty cool images
of suspended water bubbles and astronauts
walking on the ceilings of space shuttles.
But, the microgravity present in space also
poses some challenges - namely, the impact
it has on an astronaut's body.
We don’t really notice, because we’ve
habituated, but on planet earth, our body
is constantly working out.
Gravity pulls us down and our muscles and
bones must resist that tension to keep us
upright and moving - sorta like mini workouts.
But, in space, this tension virtually disappears.
Which is really bad, because muscles can atrophy
and bones can lose density.
Just like muscles, bones are living tissues
that need exercise to stay healthy.
This is why on average NASA astronauts spend
2.5hrs per day working out in space.
But it looks a bit different from what we
see here on earth.
Pushups, jumping jacks, running, or anything
really that doesn’t involve equipment, just
doesn’t work for them.
They use special exercise machines.
The three main ones at the International Space
Station are the Colbert, Cevis, and Ared.
The Colbert, named after this guy, is actually
short for Combined Operational Load Bearing
External Resistance Treadmill.
It is basically a treadmill but astronauts
must be harnessed in place.
The Cevis or Cycle Ergometer with Vibration
Isolations and Stabilization System is like
a bicycle, but because without gravity you
can’t sit down, astronauts stand and strap
their feet to pedals.
Lastly, the ARED or Advanced Resistive Exercise
Device resembles a weight training machine
which can be used for things like deadlifts,
calf raises and squats through a piston-driven
vacuum cylinder and flywheel system.
All of these modifications are necessary because
objects lack any weight and regular lifting
would be way too easy.
So does this mean all regular exercise is
easier in space?
Not, exactly.
Zero gravity does mean that the lack of resistance
might make it easier for astronauts to lift
things that would weigh hundreds of pounds
on earth.
But here’s the thing.
While in space your body fluids, sort of just
float all around your body.
Without gravity there is nothing to pull blood
down below the heart to your legs and toes.
The vast majority of blood just hangs out
around the heart and head.
So astronauts have less plasma and red blood
cells to carry oxygen to their muscles.
This is a problem for things like running
or burpees because the lack of oxygen can
cause dizziness, and therefore impede performance.
Still, despite the hours spent working out
everyday with specialized equipment, astronauts
bodies take a toll.
On average, NASA reports that they suffer
decreases of 11 to 17% of their muscular strength
and about 10% of their muscle endurance.
Their bone density also tends to decrease
about 2 to 7%.
And according to an International Space Station
scientist, about 80% report feeling lightheaded
shortly after returning to earth.
This is largely why scientists have multiple
studies underway to figure out how to improve
exercise in space and diminish the negative
health effects
of spaceflight.